I'm going to remind you of what these
mean and why their combinations of
regions and not just one region which is
what they look like so there we go this
let's do a really really simple idea
when you see when you see for instance
like remember i started previous lesson
and I started this lesson thinking 2d
and then you apply what you know in 3d
which are very good at by the way too
sorry 11 dimensional on the material
over to two-dimensional okay this is
confusing let's just think about it in
one-dimensional terms if for instance i
gave you use if for instance i gave you
that what would it mean what kind of
values would satisfy this okay um well
you want to be less than two right do
you like 0 is lesson 2 1 is less than 21
and a half is less than 2 and so on and
so on what does that absolute value add
to this it means i can put in a negative
and it's still okay right but not only
that my negatives conquer too far can
they for instance if I slap in minus 3
negative 3 right this left hand side
will become positive 3 is I've
production values around I'm positive 3
is not less than two so what does this
look like
yeah yeah inclusive or not inclusive
naughty cuisine okay can you see that
you understand so what that really means
is like think back to the first example
I started the morning with right this is
really this is two inequalities in
disguise the intersection of two
inequalities right what it really is is
X is going to be greater than negative 2
and X has got to be less than positive 2
ok or if you want to write it one more
way right it's soo has to be between
these guys right so generally speaking
and this will actually be useful for
when you start the HSE tuna course and
we talked about series and sequences and
infinite series that converge still even
though they go forever this you can
generalize to this ok so now however
here have a look have a look what does
that tell us about this I've got the
absolute value of something less than
value the absolute value something less
than a value ok what it's really meaning
is that's something it's got to be
between negative and positive right so i
can rewrite this guy i can rewrite it as
negative for less than 2x plus y less
than 0 that's just two inequalities you
can deal with that and you just want for
the same time we have divided up this
thing which looks like one inequality
we've divided up into the two parts it
really has right so you've got i can
write this two ways
I'll do everything you've got minus 4 is
less than 2x plus y okay and then you've
got 2x plus y is less than four okay now
remember you could just think about this
in purely algebraic terms and but as
much as possible I think it's wise to
move in the direction of thinking
direction right okay we want to think
about up down left right wherever we
care now neither of these inequalities
are in a state but we can think about up
down left right but they're not hard to
reshape into questions that would do
that right how are we arrange them for
example if I wanted it to be in terms of
up down if I want to look these and say
oyama bar or no I'm below however you
write for example this first equation
what do I want yeah yeah yeah good I
want to make why the subject to the
equation right so here's I'm going to do
um I guess I'll leave that why then and
i'll say why is that way and if i put
the minus 2x minus 4 like so okay to
make why the subject i will just do this
okay so immediately I see okay if I can
draw minus 2x minus four which is not
difficult i can put those intercepts on
in a second okay quattro way sorry
that's 2x4 fulness go the other way um I
know I'm going to be above this line so
let's try there we go better ok so I'm
going to be above that one above it then
we do the same thing for this guy why is
already over here this is going to be
less than minus 2x plus 4 right same
gradient minus 2x but it's above right
so he's a parallel lines very good so if
that's a lock that in as negative 4 so
plus 4 is going to have to be about the
same
distance right off there so is what I'm
getting looks like make sure they're
parallel because I'm saying you're
parallel to minus 2x plus 4 and thinking
directionally I'm above this one I'm
below this one right so therefore I'm
between these two lines I'm in here
luckily for you no points of
intersection between the two heights
because they're parallel so don't need
to worry about those are there any other
bits of information that might be useful
yeah good in fact I cut through my
region backs on studio or four of these
intercepts right or 400 so therefore
what oh my god i've got i've already put
on minus 4 that'll be for all of this
guy d 2 2 and minus negative 2 done
that's it